В ефірі «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом та Ханною Ціммерман.
Усім доброго вечора!
Питання, котре хвилює сьогодні багатьох:
Пропозиція посередництва - це реальні наміри
чи просто підступна кремлівська пропаганда?
Цю тему підняв сьогодні російський газовий лобіст,
колишній канцлер Німеччини,﻿ Ґерхард Шредер
в інтерв'ю для журналу «Stern», після розмови
з Володимиром Путіним у Москві.
Це був мікс конкретних пропозицій,
виправдовування власної позиції та міркувань, автором котрих
цілком міг бути сам президент Росії.
Шредер звинуватив свого наступника на посаді
і партійного товариша по СДПН
у тому, що той говорив неправду в цій
дивній нервовій війні
за відремонтовану газову турбіну.
Сьогодні чинний Федеральний канцлер
стоїть перед тією ж турбіною
і застерігає, щоб не попастися на вудочку Росії.
Детальніше про події - Клаус Бродбек.
Вся справа у цій турбіні в місті Мюльгайм-ан-дер-Рур:
18 тонн та близько 90 000 кінських сил.
Турбіна, відсутність якої ймовірно стала причиною
різкого скорочення транспортування газу з Росії.
Канцлер Німеччини знаходиться тут сьогодні,
щоб тримати удар путінської пропаганди:
Німеччина блокує
подальше транспортування до
газогону «Північний потік-1».
Вона - реальна, знаходиться поруч зі мною
і готова до запуску.
Пам'ятаймо, що ми живемо в світі,
де сьогодні дуже просто транспортувати турбіну.
Варто тільки сказати:
«Будь ласка, надішліть її».
Але турбіна все ще стоїть
і виконує демонстративну функцію для газової компанії Росії «Газпром»,
якій належить трубопровід,
що зараз ледь чи газ досягає Західної Європи.
З технічної точки зору це неправильно.
На вулиці Портовій, у Росії, таких турбін є 6,
а ще є 2 менші.
Їм необхідно тільки 5 з них,
щоб забезпечити 100% потужність.
Одна з них працює сьогодні.
З технічної точки зору ми не можемо цього зрозуміти.
А жодної іншої інформації у нас немає,
чому досі відсутня готовність до експлуатації.
Але пропагандист Путіна працює саме сьогодні, саме він.
Колишній канцлер Німеччини Ґерхард Шредер
у своєму інтерв'ю закликає ввести в експлуатацію
путінський газогін
«Північний потік-2», проігнорувавши
війну з Україною.
Якщо стане справді кепсько, є цей газогін,
а з двома газогонами
«Північний потік» у нас не буде проблем із
постачанням газу
для німецької промисловості та домогосподарств».
«Північний потік 1» має достатньо потужності,
там взагалі немає браку можливостей.
Всі договори, котрі Росія уклала зі всією Європою,
можна виконувати за допомогою цього трубопроводу,
і навіть газогону в Україні, який все ще є в експлуатації.
Шредер не був би собою, якби не зробив на це ставку.
Він знову зустрівся з Путіним.
І одразу після того, як вантажне судно з зерном
нарешті змогло покинути територію України,
транслює це як добрий знак.
«Хороша новина полягає в тому, що Кремль прагне перемовин,
першим успіхом є угода про зерно, можливо її вдасться
поступово розширити до припинення вогню»
На жаль, ми не бачимо жодних ознак того,
що Путін справді бажає вести перемовини.
Першим кроком було б,
якби Путін хоча б зараз припинив
обстрілювати мирне населення
та скидати ракети на міста.
Це було б кращою новиною,
аніж ті висловлювання, що
ми зараз почули від пана Шредера.
Звичайно, йдеться про щось більше аніж ця газова турбіна.
Військовий історик з університету Потсдама
Зьонке Найтцель інтенсивно досліджує
цей конфлікт, щоб зрозуміти можливі шляхи його вирішення.
Добрий вечір!
Раді Вас вітати у нас в ефірі, професоре.
Доброго вечора, Зіверсе!
Ґерхард Шредер обмовився про хороші прогнози:
Кремль готовий до перемовин.
Чи почули особисто Ви
щось у словах колишнього канцлера
про те, що стало б відправною точкою для переговорів?
Ні.
Це, звичайно, також неправильно -
заздалегідь засуджувати Шредера.
Це перша реакція, але потрібно спокійно
переглянути інтерв’ю, щоб побачити, що він каже.
Але на мою думку, у його інтерв'ю немає вагомої основи.
Те, що він пропонує,
це погодитися із визнанням Криму.
За допомогою мовної політики досягти
кантонального врегулювання на Донбасі.
Та відмову України від членства в НАТО.
Це ті моменти, які Росія цілком могла проговорити
з Заходом
до 24 лютого, щоб не починати війну з Україною.
Я бачу в цьому інтерв'ю тільки
уривчасті ствердження.
Відсутня будь-яка суттєва пропозиція.
Також наболіле питання щодо знаменитого
газогону і турбіни.
З моєї точки зору, Шредер каже неправдиву,
тобто, що Путін прагне вирішення конфлікту шляхом перемовин.
Я цього не бачу.
Крім того, ще не минув навіть тиждень,
як Лавров казав, що Україну потрібно знищити.
Не можна ігнорувати той факт, що кожного дня
російська артилерія
обстрілює українські території 4-5 тисячами гармат.
Щодня гине близько 30 українських солдат.
Хіба це схоже на переговори?
Шредер також сказав, що марно сподіватися на те,
що президент Росії віддасть Крим.
І є коло людей, які підтримують цю думку, чи не так?
Так, і я також віднесу себе до цієї групи людей.
Я не можу уявити, щоб
президент Росії віддав би Крим.
Я також не бачу, щоб Україна була боєздатно готова
повернути Крим.
Ми дискутували про те, що, можливо,
у кращому випадку, Україні
вдасться відвоювати сухопутний коридор.
Але це також викликає багато запитань.
На мій погляд, Україні не вистачає передумов,
щоб відвоювати Крим.
Це потребує юридичного визнання,
а цього ніколи не буде.
Хоча можна змиритися з нормативними силами
фактичної ситуації,
як це було у випадку Заходу щодо анексії Криму.
На думку Шредера, Донбас матиме такий самий
статус, як кантони у Швейцарії?
Наразі це взагалі незрозуміло.
Путін не захоче повернути Донбас
подібно до того, як це є з Кримом.
Тим паче, що він завоював його, почавши війну та
проливши кров своїх воїнів.
А тепер давайте подумаємо про
Луганську Народну Республіку.
Просто віддати?
Спочатку планувалося зробити
дві народні республіки, які
є частиною України, але з мовною
політикою, тобто, власною мовою.
Я собі взагалі не можу таке уявити.
Максимальна ціль, яка, на мій погляд,
є реалістичною, це
можливе повернення на попередні позиції.
На лінію, котра існувала 24 лютого.
Навіть це для України було б величезним успіхом.
Але я бачу, що Путін взагалі не готовий з таким погодитися.
Багато людей у Німеччині запитують:
Скільки часу ще триватиме війна?
Чи існує вірогідність ведення переговорів?
Що ж насправді має статися,
щоб переговори стали реальними?
Війни починаються, тому що обидві держави вважають,
що за допомогою зброї можна
«нав'язати» свою волю противнику.
А закінчуються тоді, коли або це вдається, або ж тоді,
коли розуміють, що не просуваються у своїх намірах.
Або ж у них просто закінчуються ресурси.
Потрібно йти на компроміс.
На мою думку, зараз до цього не готова жодна зі сторін.
Я не думаю, що Україна вважає,
що її військові можливості вичерпано.
Я бачу, що Генштаб ЗСУ сподівається
відвоювати сухопутний коридор південніше Запоріжжя.
І я думаю, що Путін, принаймні за своєю логікою, вважає,
що він ще не розіграв усіх своїх військових карт.
Це не означає, що вони ніколи не знайдуть
компромісного рішення,
але, вважаю, знайдуть його точно не зараз.
Через рік ситуація може бути іншою.
Але дуже малоймовірно, що впродовж цього року
досягнуть стабільного перемир'я та знайдуть
стабільне компромісне рішення.
Ще одне коротке питання.
Пане професоре, як ми взагалі маємо сприймати
будь-які домовленості з Володимиром Путіним?
Після всього, що ми вже пережили, чи зможемо ми
покладатися на майбутні угоди?
Покладатися на них, звісно, ​​не можна.
Але це все одно краще, ніж нічого.
Приклад - переговори щодо експорту зерна.
Так, поки що йдеться лише про одне судно,
і ми маємо зараз почекати, щоб побачити,
як ситуація розвиватиметься далі.
Але це краще, ніж нічого.
Я завжди наполягаю на тому, що варто залучати дипломатію,
використовувати всі можливості.
Але вірити в те, що цих договорів дотримуватимуться,
ми не можемо.
На зв'язку був професор Зьонке Найтцель
з Потсдамського університету.
Професоре, красно дякую за таку аналітику!
Оскільки на російську енергію більше не можна покладатися,
гостро постає питання: що ж тепер?
«Світлофорна» коаліція у Берліні
у пошуках відповіді на це запитання
зайшла в глухий кут.
А Бельгія повідомляє,
що відтерміновує відмову від атомної енергетики -
і не на кілька місяців, а на 10 років.
Це примітно ще й тому,
що партія Зелених серед очільників уряду Бельгії,
а також тому, що ми неодноразово чули
про несправності реакторів АЕС Бельгії у минулому.
Докладніше - Флоріан Нойганн.
У середу в Юї, що за годину їзди на схід від Брюсселю,
ринковий день.
Людей цікавить все, за чим вони прийшли,
але навряд чи цей реактор,
який розташований за кілька метрів від них
та височить над маленьким містечком.
І їм, певно, доведеться жити поруч з ним довше,
ніж очікували.
Значно довше.
Це мене дуже лякає, бо він розташований
так близько до людей.
Чому б не будувати ці реактори
якнайдалі від житлових районів?
Але якщо ми не використовуватимемо атомну енергетику,
то скоро не матимемо достатньо електроенергії.
Якби ми мали щось подібне, але
без радіоактивного випромінювання,
це було б чудово, але зараз у нас немає альтернатив.
У Бельгії ще досі 40% електроенергії виробляють
на атомних електростанціях,
що набагато більше, ніж з відновлюваних джерел енергії або газу.
Однак у 2025 році від атомної енергетики мали відмовитися,
запланували це вже досить давно.
Але війна проти України, зростання цін на енергоносії
стали поворотними подіями та змінили плани.
Із 7 реакторів Бельгія планує зупинити лише 5,
а термін експлуатації 2 інших продовжить на 10 років -
до 2035 року.
Тепер реалізувати та переконати в доцільності цього
має міністерка енергетики з партії Зелених.
Нашій економіці, нашим підприємствам,
а також нашим громадянам
це гарантуватиме безпеку та спокій.
Це компроміс,
яким вона зрештою не догодить нікому -
ані своїй партії, ані лібералам,
які є членами партійної коаліції.
Наші прагнення є чіткими.
Ми маємо робити більше, ніж продовжувати
термін експлуатації лише 2 АЕС,
з однієї простої причини:
йдеться про захист клімату, а атомна енергетика
не створює викидів CO2.
Це, звісно, ​​найгірший сценарій.
Міністерка з партії Зелених відчуває такий тиск чи залякування,
що змушена погодитися на погану пропозицію.
Один чи два реактори не мають великого значення
для енергетичної безпеки,
але спричиняють багато технічних проблем.
АЕС в окрузі Тіанж, Бельгія -
зокрема щодо неї вказують на несправності
та проблеми з гарантуванням безпеки.
Щоправда, лише найновіший із 3 реакторів
продовжуватиме працювати,
але навіть йому майже 40 років,
через що стурбовані не лише в Аахені,
що розташований зовсім неподалік.
Радіоактивність не обмежена.
Саме тому ведуть переговори, які мають допомогти Бельгії
все ж скоротити термін експлуатації АЕС.
Бельгія змінює курс щодо ядерної політики.
Питання у тому, як це допоможе у короткостроковій перспективі.
Реактори все одно працюватимуть наступної зими.
І перш ніж продовжити термін експлуатації реакторів,
доведеться витратити чимало коштів на їхній ремонт.
Атомна енергетика також відіграє важливу роль в Україні,
і нині ситуація з АЕС викликає велике занепокоєння
з огляду на війну.
Продовжить цю тему Ханна.
Йдеться про найбільшу АЕС в Європі.
Генеральний директор
Міжнародної агенції з атомної енергії (МАГАТЕ)
дуже занепокоєний ситуацією
на Запорізькій АЕС.
З березня станція контролюється російськими військами,
і, як заявив на пресконференції Рафаель Гроссі,
«ситуація дуже хитка і повністю вийшла з-під контролю».
Постійно надходять повідомлення про бої
навколо електростанції,
і тому необхідно, щоб МАГАТЕ терміново
провела оцінку безпеки на АЕС.
Після кількох місяців блокади Росією
перше судно з українським зерном
вийшло із Чорного моря.
В Стамбулі міжнародні експерти перевірили вантаж судна RAZONI,
після чого дозволили продовжувати рух.
Тепер судно може доставити в Ліван
понад 26 тисяч тонн зерна.
Наступними днями очікується відправлення
інших суден із зерном
з українських портів.
Протягом кількох місяців з Іраном не вели
жодних переговорів щодо ядерної угоди,
а сьогодні США та Тегеран оголосили
про відновлення переговорів
та планують зустрітися з іншими учасниками переговорного процесу
завтра ﻿у Відні.
Метою є відновлення Іранської ядерної угоди 2015 року,
яка спрямована на те, щоб Іран не розробляв ядерну зброю.
Експрезидент США Дональд Трамп
розірвав угоду у 2018 році.
Минув майже 31 рік після підпалу
тимчасового житла для шукачів притулку
в місті Саарлуї.
Сьогодні Федеральна прокуратура Німеччини
висунула обвинувачення правому екстремісту.
Прокуратура звинувачує ймовірного злочинця у вбивстві,
замаху на умисне вбивство 20 осіб,
а також в підпалі, що спричинив смерть,
та був замахом на умисне вбивство.
У вересні 1991 року внаслідок підпалу
загинув 27-річний чоловік із Гани.
Підозрюваний перебуває під вартою з квітня.
Тепер Вищий регіональний суд Кобленца
має вирішити, чи відбудеться судовий розгляд.
Є країни, де люди
можуть і хочуть згадувати про це лише примарно:
«Коронавірус? Що це було?»
Є країни, де досі діють суворі правила.
Ми знову і знову зіштовхуємося з цим різноманіттям
поглядів та правил.
Деякі люди вирішили
не дотримуватися карантинних заходів,
інші ж затримують дихання щоразу,
коли хтось знімає маску в поїзді.
Єдиного погляду щодо коронавірусу немає. Як раніше, так і досі.
Не дивно, що щодо питання про те, які закони діятимуть в Німеччині,
коли настане осінь, а рівень захворюваності може зрости,
міністру охорони здоров'я Німеччини, який постійно
про щось попереджає,
вдалося досягти компромісу з міністром юстиції,
який завжди демонстративно розслаблений.
Цікавим також є те,
як вони сьогодні презентували
свій проєкт закону «Про захист від інфекцій»:
один - зі свого офісу, другий - з місця відпочинку під час відпустки.
Детальніше - Андреа Маурер.
Міністр охорони здоров'я та міністр юстиції
довго змагалися.
Це було нелегко.
Не секрет,
що Карл Лаутербах прагнув активніших дій ще раніше.
А Марко Бушман каже, що не треба
керуватися акціонізмом,
і сьогодні, начебто на доказ цього,
під'єднується до презентації проєкту,
перебуваючи на відпочинку у відпустці.
Усі ці речі, які ми розуміємо під терміном «локдаун»:
комендантська година, закриття підприємств та шкіл -
усі ці речі ми більше не вважаємо доречними.
Згідно з проєктом, цією осінню
застосують концепцію багаторівневого захисту.
Основний засіб захисту - маска.
У всій країні обов'язковим буде носіння масок
у повітряному та міжміському транспорті.
В лікарнях і будинках для людей похилого віку -
обов'язкове тестування та носіння маски.
Федеральні землі можуть вирішувати самостійно
щодо обов'язкового носіння маски
в громадських закритих приміщеннях
та в школах, але лише з 5 класу.
У ресторанах, театрах або спортзалах маску можуть не носити
вакциновані, ті, хто має негативний тест,
і ті, хто нещодавно перехворів.
Обмеження встановлює вже не держава,
а федеральні землі.
Залежно від ситуації вони можуть
посилити масковий режим.
Критика з Баварії:
Хороші наміри ще не означають хороші результати.
Залишається багато питань, які потрібно роз'яснити.
Я хотів би, щоб наші задуми і плани
були простішими
і зрозумілішими для громадян.
Щоб було чітко визначено,
коли і які заходи слід вживати.
Тут багато питань,
які повинні бути роз'яснені.
І саме цього я очікую від уряду.
Міністр охорони здоров'я Німеччини заявив,
що восени будуть доступні
чотири нові вакцини.
І визначив поняття «нещодавно вакцинований» так:
мінімум третє щеплення, зроблене не раніше, ніж 3 місяці тому.
Тож четверта доза вакцини необхідна, але коли?
Якщо ви зараз хочете отримати цю дозу,
наприклад, щоб відвідувати ресторани, кафе, бари восени,
коли з 1-го жовтня почнуть діяти нові правила,
тоді, звичайно, варто почекати нових вакцин.
Але якщо є високий ризик захворіти у тяжкій формі,
то я б точно не відкладав вакцинацію.
Восени нещодавно отримана доза вакцини
знову стане необхідністю.
24 серпня Кабмін Німеччини планує
розпочати внесення змін до законодавства.
Нові правила діятимуть від жовтня до Великодня.
«Китай не може перешкоджати світовим політикам
відвідувати Тайвань», - сказала Ненсі Пелосі,
спікерка Палати представників Конгресу США,
третя людина в американській політиці
після президента й віцепрезидентки.
І сама ж приголомшливо це продемонструвала.
Її візит до Тайваню був знаком солідарності з островом,
його мешканцями, тамтешньою динамічною демократією
і правом висловлювати свою думку.
Знаком того, що США на боці Тайваню
всупереч відкритим загрозам з Пекіна.
З одного боку.
З іншого боку це було ходіння по лезу ножа,
тому що влада Китаю сприйняла цей візит як виклик.
І гнівно відреагувала.
Навіть Ненсі Пелосі складно
точно оцінити небезпеку неконтрольованої ескалації.
Детальніше Ульф Реллер.
Почнемо трохи з іншого.
Китай більше не транспортує рибу-шаблю до Тайваню.
Вона у санкційному списку, як і цитрусові.
Шляхи любові та гніву лежать у Пекіні через шлунок.
По телебаченню державні ЗМІ
готують громадян до кризи.
«Китайська народна армія», - каже ведучий, -
«перебуває у стані підвищеної готовності».
Китай дуже хотів запобігти цій зустрічі.
Президентка Тайваню Цай Інвень вітає
спікерку Палати представників США Ненсі Пелосі.
Повідомлення для Пекіну:
США захищатимуть самостійність Тайваню.
Пелосі знає силу своїх слів,
знає, що вони стривожать регіон.
Ми відчуваємо відповідальність за безпеку Тайваню
і хочемо, щоб країна сама могла захистити себе.
Йдеться про демократію і свободу,
які Тайвань так зразково репрезентує.
Доки Пелосі говорить ці слова,
війська Китаю вже кілька годин перебувають у русі.
Влада наказала провести десятки військових
маневрів навколо Тайваню.
Місцеві жителі бояться, що
Китай перекриє повітряний простір і морські шляхи.
Адже китайські війська проводять навчання у бойовій готовності.
Пекін хоче об'єднання з Тайванем,
за потреби навіть шляхом військового насилля.
Тайвань ніколи не був незалежною країною.
З історичної точки зору існує лише
провінція Китайської Народної Республіки.
Національна пропаганда працює на повну потужність.
За допомогою цих навчань Китай хоче
продемонструвати свою силу,
але багатьом китайцям в мережі цього недостатньо.
Вони закликають напасти на Тайвань.
Візит Пелосі для них як ляпас.
У соцмережах поширюється нестандартний протест.
Президент Сі у напрузі, бо він не може
показати себе слабким перед народом.
Водночас він, ймовірно,
не хотів би, аби дійшло до військового конфлікту.
Для Сі Цзіньпіна це передусім демонстрація сили,
демонстрація образів, картинок для власної аудиторії,
для власних політичних еліт.
Думаю, в короткостроковій перспективі він бачить,
що Китай не в змозі перемогти у такому військовому конфлікті
без екзистенційних ризиків.
На одному з пляжів Китаю,
близько 160 км від узбережжя Тайваню,
демонстративно проїжджають танки.
Поки що Пекін просто інсценує «битву образів».
Але вона хвилює регіон.
Попри невеликий розмір Тайвань
має величезне значення для світу.
Тепер це знову стало очевидно, Ханна.
Йдеться про зовсім дрібні частинки,
без яких практично ніщо у світі не працює.
Тайвань - лідер на ринку виробництва напівпровідників.
Вони є майже усюди -
від смартфона до обладнання на підприємстві.
Тож ми значно залежимо від острова.
Стефані Баррет з Франкфурта.
Яку роль це відіграє у конфлікті?
Насправді центральну роль.
Стратеги вважають домінування Тайваню
у сфері напівпровідників
його найважливішою гарантією безпеки,
своєрідним щитом з кремнію.
Адже не тільки Китай і США -
уся світова економіка залежить
від сучасних напівпровідників Тайваню.
Охоплюючи 64% світового ринку,
Тайвань значно випереджає Південну Корею та Китай.
Тайвань єдиний зробив ставку
на напівпровідники ще 40 років тому
і, залучивши державні мільярди, побудував
найбільшу у світі компанію з виготовлення чіпів - TSMC.
Цю назву мало хто знає,
але її чіпи можна знайти всюди:
як у дуже складних аерокосмічних машинах,
так і в простих елементах управління
автомобілів чи холодильників.
Ці напівпровідники важливі не лише для Заходу.
Вони надзвичайно потрібні для модернізації Китаю.
Там їх взагалі вважають
найважливішим імпортним товаром.
Якщо США все більше віддалятимуться від Китаю,
КНР ризикує
втратити доступ до тайванських напівпровідників.
Це може пояснити показові військові ігри.
Проте пік конфронтації вже минув.
На міжнародних фінансових ринках зітхнули з полегшенням.
Індекс Dax зріс на 1% після закінчення торгів.
Проте інвестори все ще стурбовані через такі напружені події.
Стефані, дякую за оцінку.
Після попереджувального страйку наземного персоналу
авіакомпанія Lufthansa та профспілка ver.di
продовжили переговори щодо оплати праці.
ver.di вимагає підвищення зарплати на 9,5%
для приблизно 20 000 співробітників.
Переговори триватимуть два дні.
Відсутність згоди означатиме нові страйки.
Минулої середи майже всі рейси Lufthansa
були скасовані через страйк працівників.
А тепер виграшні номери лотереї цієї середи.
Ви бачите їх на екрані.
Усі дані, як завжди, без гарантій.
Таким був наш світ цієї середи.
Дякую за ваш інтерес.
Побачимося завтра.
Бувайте!
Добрий вечір! Це прогноз погоди.
Знову наближається хвиля спеки.
Цього разу з Іспанії через Францію до Німеччини.
Завтра вона досягне піку.
До нас доходить холодний фронт,
який потіснить спеку на південний схід.
Це виглядає ось так:
ця «бульбашка» спеки підіймається з південного заходу,
а потім посувається на південний схід.
У найближчу ніч ніяких особливих погодних умов.
Ясно, зірки сяятимуть при температурах,
які де-не-де опустяться трохи нижче 20°C.
Особливо в містах буде дуже тепло.
Найхолодніше на південному сході 14°C.
Завтра буде сонячно, а у другій половині дня
з північного заходу прийдуть зливи та грози.
Максимальна температура -
до 39°C на південному заході.
Можливо досягне й 40°C.
37°C на сході,
а найменш спекотно біля Північного моря - 27°C.
Завтра ввечері зливи та грози
рухатимуться вглиб країни.
Разом із сильним дощем, градом
та поривами вітру.
У п'ятницю грози слід очікувати в центрі та на півдні.
Температура - до 35°C.
А з суботи вже буде не так спекотно. Гарного вечора!